in 1947 I only wanted to be in the
movies because we were talking about it
but I never had any idea that I'd get so
involved that it would embrace my life
and it would change everything I do to
accommodate it did I want to direct when
I first got to Hollywood no I had no
idea what that was about
but when I started to go to the sound
department and the camera department and
the editing department and the scoring
stage I was learning what that's about
and I couldn't get enough information I
would leave the camera department I go
right over to editing it's the questions
I asked and the wonderful thing about
every member of every crew that I worked
with this way was so thrilled that I
thought it was wonderful that I wanted
to learn it like he's landed you can't
give that man a better gift than telling
him you want to be just like him I
learned through every member of my crews
it was wonderful the technical aspect of
our industry if you haven't got that you
might as well not do it because the
technical is as critical as the written
word and when I finish a screenplay I
know what I have to have on the set and
sometimes I bring a pressure to the crew
because I've already got it locked in
the way I know it's going to be in the
movie and now we're gonna shoot it so
that's a little thing that gets in your
way sometimes if you're overly anxious
you got to look at your crew and find
out where the best people are and keep
them close to you because they will give
you answers to questions you may not
have ever had before and it's not bad
having a guy that's been in the business
35 years standing over there with a
booming 'san and you
say to Amend how's this gonna do just do
it it's gonna be fine
it's it's when the crew knows of your
love for what you're doing they fall in
love with it ultimately they think
they're just getting in bed with you
well after a little while they recognize
they're doing exactly what I'm doing and
it's coming from an emotional passionate
place and they can't wait to come to
work every day when I get gooseflesh I
know I'm on the right track
and that's passion and emotion and they
are feelings that you cannot disconnect
from if you're gonna be a good filmmaker
you have to come with that information
you have to find out what you do to get
it and the answers are very simple you
have to just free your mind of what
you're thinking and let it come into the
foreground you know so many people say
well I don't know if he'll like that
don't bring someone a creative idea that
way
you've lost he's not we're gonna hear it
you have to say that's emotion or that's
passion I got to listen to that more you
see when I yell roll something happens
it's critical to me I've opened the eyes
of the world Russians are gonna see this
the Chinese children are gonna see it
the Japanese children are gonna see it
there's so much good stuff that comes
from doing good work